Ray it's a treat to be here with you
um uh Ray and our old friends and um
I've been in conversation before
um I wonder if you just start Ray by
sharing with me with the crowd um why as
a macro investor you decide to step back
and write this book on principles of a
changing World Order and then let's go
into the the uh the key principles
okay
I learned a while ago that the things
that were coming at me that I had to
deal with often surprised me if they
didn't happen in my lifetime but I found
that they happen many times in history
uh first time that it happened I was
clerking on the floor of the New York
Stock Exchange 1971 August 15th
President Nixon gets on the television
and says that they're going to default
on the obligation to turn cash money
into gold
so I went on the floor of the stock
exchange I expected of code down a lot
it went up a lot and I was real
surprised
because I never had a currency
devaluation in your in your experience
in my life yeah I went back and I
studied and I found the exact same thing
happen on March 3rd March 5th 1933 with
Roosevelt doing the same thing on a
radio and I studied why and I studied
the currency so what happened for me is
there are three big things that are
coming at us in our lifetimes now that
didn't exist before and that's the
amount of debt creation and the
monetization of that debt in other words
central banks printing money and buying
all that debt never happened in that
magnitude
the second is the amount of internal
conflict that political and so on was
the largest wealth gaps since the 1930
to 45 period the largest
political gaps by any measures the
largest amount of populism I never saw
in my lifetime those two things
um and at ozica
number three was of course the changing
World geopolitical situation well I'm in
my lifetime in our lifetimes we have
never seen a power
being comparable right to the United
States in power we saw the Soviet Union
but they were not economically powerful
and it's very very apparent that there's
that rivalry and and conflict between
them those through three things all of
them
um never happened before in our
lifetimes but all happened in the 1930
to 45 period
and then I said I I need to understand
those and I need to understand like I'm
dealing with the Rises and declines of
Reserve currencies and then they follow
the Rises and declines of Empires and in
order since they have an ark that's a
long Arc but it's right on top of this I
needed to go back the last 500 years and
see that cycle and then I saw two more
factors which I'll get into in a minute
so let's go into that you basically
identified five factors of that account
for the rise and fall of countries and
um uh economies geopolitical systems you
produced a video
um to identify this can we can we see
that sure I'll tell you the two others
that I discovered when I was there and
when you have a Confluence of these you
changed the world order and when I say
order I mean there's a system
we have a political system that's in
order we have a world system how it
works is the system and we're changing
how that works and so the two others
that I found was that acts of nature
droughts floods and pandemics had a
bigger effect on toppling civilizations
and causing more deaths than the first
three I mentioned interesting and of
course very relevant to now what you're
watching and then number five is the
biggest force over a long period of time
is uh man's learning and technologies
that they make as a result of that
learning over a period of time so when
we think of Technology as having an
effect okay all five of those things are
the five Great forces and how they
relate to each other so I think each one
of them so what I wanted to do was I
found it important other sounded
important and I wanted it was a study
that I was using to deal with today
right my positions today are driven by
that yes
and I decided that I was going to put
this study out as a book and then to try
to communicate clearly I did a video
it's uh it's about a 40 minute video uh
animated video but I'm taking a clip of
it and this just sort of describes the
cycle that we see happening over and
over again so great how these five keep
repeating themselves at different points
in history with different powers right
and that yes we'll see It'll speak for
itself cue the video
I studied the 10 most powerful Empires
over the last 500 years and the last
three Reserve currencies it took me
through the rise and decline of the
Dutch Empire and the Gilder
the British Empire and the pound
the rise and early decline in the United
States Empire in the dollar
and The Decline and Rise of the Chinese
Empire and its currencies as well as the
rise and decline of the Spanish German
French Indian Japanese Russian and
ottoman Empires along with their
significant conflicts
as measured in this chart
to understand China's patterns better I
also studied the rise and fall of
Chinese dynasties and their monies back
to the year 600. because looking at all
these measures at once can be confusing
all focus on the four most important
ones the Dutch British U.S and Chinese
you'll quickly notice the pattern
now let's simplify the form of it as you
can see they transpired an overlapping
cycles that lasted about 250 years with
10 to 20-year transition periods between
them
typically these transitions have been
periods of great conflict because
leading Powers don't decline without a
fight so how am I measuring an Empire's
power
in this study I used eight metrics each
country's measure of total power is
derived by averaging them together they
are education inventiveness and
Technology development competitiveness
in global markets economic output share
of World Trade military strength the
power of their financial center for
Capital markets and the strength of
their currency as a reserve currency
because these powers are measurable we
can see how strong each country is now
was in the past and whether they're
rising or declining
by examining the sequences from many
countries
we can see how a typical cycle
transpires
and because the Wiggles can be confusing
we can simplify it a bit to focus on the
pattern of cause effect relationships
that drive the rise and decline of a
typical Empire
as you can see better education
typically leads to increased Innovation
and Technology development and with a
lag the establishment of the currency as
a reserve currency
you can also see that these forces then
declined in a similar order reinforcing
each other's decline
let's now look at the typical sequence
of events going on inside a country that
produces these Rises and declines in a
nutshell the big cycle typically begins
after a major conflict often a war
establishes the new leading power and
the New World Order because no one wants
to challenge this power a period of
peace and prosperity typically follows
as people get used to this peace and
prosperity they increasingly Bet On It
continuing they borrow money to do that
which eventually leads to a financial
bubble the Empire share of trade grows
and when most transactions are conducted
in its currency it becomes a reserve
currency which leads to even more
at the same time this increased
Prosperity distributes wealth unevenly
so the wealth Gap typically grows
between the rich Haves and the poor
have-nots
eventually the financial bubble bursts
which leads to the printing of money
and increased internal conflict between
the rich and the poor which leads to
some form of Revolution to redistribute
wealth this can happen peacefully or as
a civil war while the Empire struggles
with this internal conflict its power
diminishes relative to external rival
powers on the rise when a new Rising
power gets strong enough to compete with
the dominant power that is having
domestic breakdowns external conflicts
most typically Wars take place out of
these internal and external Wars come
new winners and losers then the winners
get together to create the New World
Order and the cycle begins again
um it's a little scary because it's a
little um it's quite Bleak when it comes
to America
um in terms of where we are in your
cycle where China is and even if China
weren't Rising
um uh you can't watch that video and
watch the evening news without thinking
yikes
um you know that uh curve is heading
down well I'm I have to be a realist I
have to make bets on what's likely to
occur and uh and I have a principle if
you worry you don't need to worry if you
don't worry you need to worry
okay I like that because if you worry
about that right then maybe you'll do
something about it right right in other
words I think if we worry about that
maybe we'll do the healthy things right
these basic healthy yes broad-based
education equal opportunity how do you
get out of it yes right that's
interesting um do you
see anything right now and we'll move on
to China in a second but in America
where you think maybe the alarm is being
heard and we can
um reverse that curve
um the alarms I think are beginning to
be heard okay I thought the last midterm
elections yes there was less of a move
the extremist loss right yes okay I
think you need a strong middle yes and
then you have to do healthy things
interesting the magnitudes of that
movement are very small really relative
to the issues yes like this dealing with
the debt ceiling yeah you know it's
ridiculous right how it how it happens
right nobody does anything really they
just and they go on right okay yeah so
the finances haven't changed yes and so
on I mean there are there are glimmers
but you have a you have a structural
issue it it's just like if you got
deeper into debt
you're not as healthy as you were it's
like if you smoked and didn't exercise
or something right you're not as healthy
as you were so when you think about the
debt all the amount of money
that everybody's holding a death expects
to get a real return on that yes and you
think okay it's not like you didn't have
the debt and so you have to make let's
take the economic one you have to
earn more than you spend right I mean
it's that's the basics you have to earn
more than you spend and and in order to
get healthy well that means that you
either have to cut your spending and
that's a problem or you have to raise
your income so it's not easy okay
um and so it's we are where we are right
and uh but it is I think I think the
real big thing is
how people are with each other in other
words if we think about the whole right
because if you take per capita income
until the highest it's been we take
Technologies and our living standards
are still in the world the highest
they've been
um but how you work that all out
domestically how are we dealing with
other immune with respect with um in a
way that can produce collaboration yeah
I like I would well not only
collaboration but I mean I think the
basics like
you look at the societies that are doing
well you have to have a basic
uh education nutrition
these types of Basics if you look at the
societies that by and large do well
throughout history and it's back to
equal opportunity more equal opportunity
nothing's perfect but you have to deal
with those structural basic issues and
it's difficult because you know
different everybody wants to hold on to
the money and of course you're deeply in
debt and then you need a lot of money
yeah
um and the hole gets deeper so China uh
Ray what what are they getting right
um relative to us and what would you say
China's getting right that most
Americans don't appreciate and
understand oh okay I I've been going to
China uh for 39 years I want to started
in 1984.
um soon after dang Xiaoping came to
power and I've been very lucky I they
didn't have many money I didn't go for
money right I went for curiosity and
then I really got to be part of helping
them build the system and so and so
forth
um and um so since I started to go per
capita income has increased by 28 times
life expectancies increased by 10 years
the poverty rate has gone from 88 to
Hungry poverty to less than one percent
these kinds of things and um and what
they got right was the reform and they
did it in a symbiotic relationship with
the United States
um in which essentially they sold us
inexpensive good value Goods that we
preferred the prices of and they lent us
the money to do it it's a difficult
relationship
um so they and and if you I studied the
dynasties going back uh over 2000 years
and what they
um they have a
oh they're intelligent they have a work
at that it's semi-confusion meaning that
they're you know orderly they're
intelligent hard-working people
um you know those basic elements they've
got right they had it the easy way
because they started with of you know
when they closed the door right from
1949 until 1978 they closed the door so
they got really backwards and so that
bounced but they have a population
that's more than four times the size of
the United States so when you get to
have
income let's say that's half the United
States so then you have an economy
that's twice the United States so
there's a great deal of uh of that I I
would say
um
their
their water lead they're disciplined
they're hard working they can be very
creative there are different cultures
within China you know the southern is
more the business Community whatever
open to the world and so on
um
I
I think that one of the things that is
not understood is how the confusion way
of thinking affects their foreign policy
oh so
um
Confucianism is an idea of how a family
should operate that within your family
you are controlling your family you have
the right be a good be a good you have
these rules
then you interact with others so it's an
extension of that they view that within
China
that that is their family they call it's
an extended family the word country in
China is two Chinese
characters which is State family okay so
and and then that also is why it's
autocratic because it's very much top
down like strict parents operating that
way
um when they're dealing with the outside
world
um a man I think that we both know Wang
XI Chun Who's the who was just the vice
president of China and so on described
to me he he said this idea of taking
over and uh proselytizing other
countries in which you want to it just
doesn't work you know if you're going to
occupy and you're taking away their
basic rights that you know that that
doesn't work Afghanistan doesn't work
that and and he said that that was the
development of the
um Mediterranean culture and he
described that up really to the piece of
Westphalia when they had 30 Years War
and then we came up with the idea that
we would make a country and we would
make borders and that with those within
the borders would control how they did
things and those outside so when we
think of it um I think they want to be
as competitive and do as well as they
can but we you know when you ask how do
we misunderstand yes I think this idea
of fight and Conquer right is not the
same it is more of a hierarchical thing
in which those who become more powerful
all are more powerful need to be more
respected and then there's a
relationship which is most almost a
vassal safe relationship those around
them and there's a way that those who
are powerful should deal with those who
are less powerful right and those who
are less powerful should deal with those
who are more powerful that is a sort of
a mutual respect and that so I don't
think they're out to conquer the world
and I don't think they're out to have a
military power there's an argument one
could make that China got to this rise
through a very
um uh clear policy laid down by dung
Xiaoping of regular rotations in power
so the system is constantly refreshed
and that there's opportunities for
Rising people
um it was also hide your power a little
bit don't freak out the world
um and one could make the argument that
um uh seizing ping the current president
is breaking a lot of those rules he he
ended the rotate nation and power at
least by taking another five-year term
um he's freaked out I think a lot of
China's neighbors let alone us
how would you could China be at Peak
China right now not you know uh on this
upward curve how do you think about
those first of all I want to make clear
that I'm not a defender of China I'm
just an observer and you know
um and that and I'm trying to just
factually answer your questions uh to
produce understanding but not to produce
advocacy yeah I'd much rather live in
the United States and have all the
freedoms that we have and all the
blessings that we have than to be living
in China under those set of
circumstances so I just want to be clear
in doing that
um
if you study the dynasties then this is
in their minds uh Chinese study history
they all the leaders know the dynasties
there is an arc in terms of what types
of leadership what types of ways work
okay so you can have all of these
different types of styles of management
the more autocratic and not and if you
go back to Plato and he look at the
Republic and he wrote how there's an
evolution of democracies because
democracies are not A New Concept way
back then and you look at those cycles
that there is a cycle over that and we
see that cycle in the um in the history
of our own country or the history of the
world that what happens is during the
biggest risk of a demo of a democracy is
an anarchy during a difficult time then
right so in the 30s 1930 to 45 period
four major democracies chose to be
autocracy
so dang Xiaoping says that there's I
uh big storm a hundred year storm on the
horizon
Okay now what's that hundred year story
I think he does believe that we have
this issue this great power conflict
it's a big deal and then they have
internal storm they have lots of things
internally that are their problems and
he wants to take control of it and so I
watched the evolution of that from Deng
Xiaoping I think if you exactly you
described it very well you know
um
when you have power you hide it and when
you don't have power you show it as much
as you can you know and that whole
process absolutely and then if you
couldn't hide it anymore and you moved
beyond that and so
um we're part of that cycle I think I
think they view that as part of that
cycle that's where they are now your
question is does it work
okay
um and I think the right question is
does it work better than our democracy
also which faces its particular
challenges but
um the the truth of it is I think that
it works a lot less well because
um there are big changes now
um it's no longer glorious to be rich
yeah okay the decision making is very
dictatorial from the top down which
makes it very difficult to run a country
because you at that level you're not
having it bottom up you have to control
almost all things that's a particular
challenge
um also people are afraid to make
decisions
um they're fearful you know better no
decisions than to make the wrong
decisions to get in trouble with it so
there's more fear over there and then of
course we have these other things that
are going on this great world conflict
which is having an effect on Chinese
companies and Chinese who them self say
am I you know maybe I should set my
business outside yes and foreign
countries companies too that say okay am
I going to get sanctioned and where is
it and so elsewhere in the world is
benefiting the neutral countries are
benefiting and India is benefiting the
asean country so outside of Singapore
Indonesia Vietnam all of those countries
are benefiting so let me ask um uh
country I didn't figure in here but
another big part Russia how do you see
Russia Today in terms of the the very
patterns
um and attributes of of successful
countries how do you look at poop in
Russia Today well even before even
before
very interesting
I took all of these indicators and I
could forecast pretty well you with them
the next 10 years growth rates
if the anybody wants to see them they're
in the back of the book and they're also
I update them free online so you could
see them and what Russia had
um or they basically had a cultural
problem in terms of
um
uh corruption
disorder fragmentation all the elements
that you say where you have equal
um education you educate your population
well alcoholism as a problem in terms of
those types of things their strengths
was they didn't get much in debt but
they didn't have a creativity and and
all of that technology development they
had nothing they became they're a big
resource exporter and so on so that's it
you take that away so they didn't have
the elements that I'm describing in
other words the building of the quality
education the inventiveness and all of
that problem in terms of that so that
existed before and then we have this
real screw-up to be to make this kind of
move that's right I mean it's a you know
it's a very very Bleak situation and one
might have said it when after World War
II or even in up all through many of our
years that if you were to look at Russia
and you to look at China you would say
okay well you know maybe you'd bet on
Russia yeah and do that but these
cultural issues in terms of indicators
like there's a negative 54 correlation
between corruption and the countries
next 10-year growth rates that so these
are the problems Raya for Kevin McCarthy
and and President Biden invited you into
the Oval Office right now said uh we
both read your book we see those curves
China going this way and us going that
way
what can we do in the near term okay
um
first of all
smart
bipartisanship
yeah
what's number two
[Laughter]
but no I know what you mean without that
there's okay
you we can re-engineer things
in other words there is a certain amount
of debt how do you deal with the debt
and how do you deal with the payments on
that debt how much is going to be
monetized how much is going to be
whatever it is how do you raise
productivity so that it benefits the
majority of the people let's say the
basic things like education then
civility of the population in other
words these these Basics that we're
talking about
um how do you do that
um like I basically think that if we had
a strong middle I almost don't if you
had smart bipartisan people from the
middle government
who fought for what they agreed on yes
and so on and were inventive I think
that they could deal with that I worry
about the extremes okay I worry about
the extremes the rich the poor or that
the lack of opportunity and so on yes so
um I I think smart bipartisan chip if
they said I would get together and we
will
um deal with the extremes and I think
that what you need is a
like a a Manhattan Project plan in other
words take six months
uh and bring those people together and
make them make an agreement of how that
thing works they don't come out of that
until they have an agreement of how that
thing works I think smart people could
engineer a lot in order to make that and
I I almost don't care what they've come
up with if it's smart and they're
bipartisan and then they fight the
opposite extremes the extremes I think
we'd make a lot of progress It's well uh
I think there's a lot of wisdom in that
um
Ray you alluded to India a lot of people
you know
um
think India may be the the real winner
between the competition between China
and the United States what do you see
the strengths and weaknesses of India in
terms of your framework they the the
indicators give a 10-year projected
growth rate
India has the highest projected growth
rate
um and the reason is uh some of the
indicators are
the cost of an educated person okay
education is very important but in many
places an educated person can be very
expansive right
in India they have very low costs of an
educated person okay so that means
that's powerful okay
the um level of indebtedness
if you have a high level of indebtedness
you're going to probably have a problem
they have very low levels of
indebtedness
technology development we're seeing big
leaps forward in terms of how this
incredibly poor country that doesn't
have toilets
is going to technology development in in
many ways this inventiveness and so on
so it has you know if I was to go many
of those three types of things within
this country they have
um wonderful education they have
wonderful family they have you know
there are more millionaires in India
than there are in the United States or
anywhere really so the ability to have
that middle class and to rise and then
we go back to the basics you know three
basics
are you earning more than you're
spending
as a country yeah well and it's good for
an individual too yeah okay
are you learning more than you're
spending
um are you working well together or are
you fighting with each other internally
and or you're at risk of a war
externally
if you take those criteria those basic
things your financial condition is good
you earn more than you spend so your
income statement and balance sheet are
good
you're not at work internally so you
don't have the disruption and you're not
at War externally okay you're in a good
place
what I like about yours and the other
thing about it just one more point is
if you look at the history of Wars it
might have
there's the winners the losers in the
neutral countries
the neutral countries
economically and by almost all measures
their markets their Investments do
better than even the winners
and if you're a loser it you're wiped
out okay so when we look at this types
of thing you're seeing a Prosperity
that's happening in these places places
you go to I go to you look at them you
know they're beautiful they're they're
operating efficiently and so on and
they're neutral in this
so we've got some questions from the
audience um uh you know since you wrote
the book uh chat GPT has come out
um and uh we've had this Great Leap
Forward in AI
um you know how do you think that can or
will change
um the criteria especially
for China which
um will it's got its own AI but they
will be limited when you can't ask your
AI what happened in Tiananmen Square in
June 6 1989 or write me 10 jokes about
Xi Jinping yeah I mean that will be that
will be a limiting factor I'm kind of
thinking so but how does AI figure in
now to your thesis well yeah
um
it is a tremendously powerful resource
uh not just in terms of giving you
information but
um I know somebody in terms of computer
programming nasty mountains it says go
find the mistake in the program and they
can go into it it's an incredibly
powerful thing
so how it's used is the most important
thing
and there are no regulations right
so the problem isn't with the technology
the problem is with the people and so
when we have this war okay are we going
to use it to improve mankind or and all
are we going to use it to fight so we're
in this environment in which this
incredibly powerful force is not
regulated nor any Prospect of Regulation
and we are an environment of confidence
in which most likely I worry that this
would be weaponized and there's not an
easy way around it because there's no
world government or anything like that
now you're exactly right with uh China
being behind on this yeah
um they're behind for uh two reasons
first of all the chip development is two
to four years behind on this type of
Chip
and they're worried about this because
on um in that two to four years there's
going to be a tremendous amount of
learning that they'll be behind on yes
just because of the chip development and
then it's exactly right as you say it
used to be that um when you can get all
the information because they could get
all the information all the data on
everybody on everything right and you
put AI on that wow that was a powerful
alternative plus they have eight times
as many Engineers computer engineers and
you figure wow what a competitive
advantage that really helped them on
Health Care they did a lot and official
recognition because they didn't have
privacy regulations batteries and all
sorts of things right just amazing but
when you have this impermeable bubble
right or something just as you're
referring and you can't get information
in yes or even that whole notion and
you're two years behind in terms of the
technology it's a problem and I want to
emphasize that
if we take the next 18 months to two
years
this is going to be a period of of great
disorder yeah I think I agree with you
because we have in our tightening of the
financials we have the tightening yes
and not yet the consequences so you just
think of a normal business cycle just
explain that to the audience just what
we're having a tightening okay and yet
we haven't seen the consequences I think
people would be okay
there are these Cycles you know
recession growth recession stimulation
growth Prosperity gets too hot
unemployments through low tight monetary
policy tightened stock market goes down
right and then the economy goes down
right those on average have lasted seven
years give or take about three years and
since 1945 when the new system the new
water came about there's been 12 and a
half of those so we're in the spark of
the cycle right now where they have
tightened the monetary policy interest
rates they have had the costs of those
types of this and at the part of the
cycle where just credit is beginning to
fall and the consequences of that are
going to happen and that will move us
into the next 18 months okay in terms of
the normal consequences of that meaning
a worse economy profits more
unemployment right those kinds of issues
go going into elections right okay now
in elections we have a great deal of
polarity
a great deal of polarity yeah and you
put together that with this other with
and you have the wealth Gap the rich the
poor and so on that and then you also
have the popularity of anti-china yeah
and and and that issue in terms of the
conflict going into that and in China's
case so we're taking these three forces
yeah I take the and then you have the
Chinese we are really very close to the
edge yes in terms of Brinks of yes and
it could be a sanctions War an economic
war or a military war related to Taiwan
they're both at the edge and then you
have the technology that we're just
talking about usually disruptive yeah
we're gonna feel it you're going to
start to see it in dramatic ways and
there's no order now I mean there's no
system for coordinating that right so
that's likely to be a period of
significant disorder